sous la forme très simple de battles et
à deux ans contre un sur des distances
de 50 mètres donc en sprint c'est ce qui
se passera notamment à guyancourt sur la
place du marché avec la rue jean mallet
qui va être temporairement une piste de
sprint de 50 mètres
[Musique]
d'amener l'athlétisme au sein des
quartiers qui habituellement se cantonne
plus tôt au stade et ferries association
c'est aussi de pouvoir faire rencontrer
des jeunes de quartiers différents dans
une même ville
a été un personnage très forte du sport
français est un grand champion et et il
a décidé effectivement de créer sap de
par son parcours aussi puisqu'il est
lui-même issu de ces quartiers il a
découvert l'athlétisme par les
structures et il souhaite en faire
bénéficier effectivement les jeunes de
ces quartiers
il ya 28 dates en france du mois de mai
on est con fait partie des premières et
de la première de notamment sur saint
quentin en yvelines et des yvelines
d'ailleurs il ya 28 dates jusqu'au mois
de septembre est en fait il ne reste que
le plus rapide de la session en réalité
sous la forme d'un tournoi si vous
voulez et à la fin il ya une grande
finale nationale au mois de septembre
[Musique]